what's going on there reject nation we
got yet again another clip for the
batman and guess what we do have an
early screening upcoming so this might
be the last clip we're watching like a
few of these back to back and we're just
spreading out the uploads but we haven't
seen the movie yet so you know subscribe
click that notification bell to get
notified when our review for the movie
is up we should have an early one up for
you guys next week i think when embargo
lifts yeah we're trying to watch
whatever clips have been released to the
public first to give a reaction to you
guys obviously before we watch the movie
because if we can't react to it because
there's no point but anyway
all right guys let's get into it leave a
like if you can let's do this
[Music]
some event huh
brought out the one guy in the city more
reclusive than me thought you'd never
leave the shoreline
aren't you afraid someone took a shot at
you why because your father ain't around
eyes you know bruce wayne
wow is that right his father saved my
life
i got shot in the chest
right here
i couldn't go to the hospital so we
showed up on his doorstep
operated right on the dining room table
oh [ __ ]
he saw the whole thing up on the stairs
looking down that's straight out of long
hallways i looked under your face
you don't think that meant something you
did then that means you took the
hippocratic off
hypocritical
that's good
oh man i wasn't expecting them to pull
directly from the long halloween you see
a there's a flashback of that matter of
fact a big part of batman's guilt if i'm
not mistaken last time i reread that
comic was before the second trailer came
out if i'm not mistaken that's part of
what weighs on bruce and it seems to be
applied here is like man if my dad did
not save carmine falcone maybe a lot of
this could have been prevented ah so
this does factor in a lot that wayne
legacy that we keep hearing about in the
trailers how deep does that protection
go and how maybe dastardly or insidious
was it on the wayne side ah that's
really neat to actually see this uh fly
there that's right that storyline is
stripped straight from there that gives
like a part of what a smart way to make
sure to include that because that
automatically keeps it personal between
bruce wayne and carmine falcone as well
and i'm liking the interpretation that
john turturro is doing you know i've
never really quite imagined it to be
this more subtle i've always imagined
it'd be like really like italian cakes
or cliche don't come down here with
uranga his anyways that's your car
really sort of almost bemused kind of
guy who's yeah like clearly on top of
the world unconcerned with anything
doesn't even need to bring that level of
bravado out yeah but then to see that
it's taking place at this point in the
storyline whereas like in long halloween
penguin was penguin by that point he
wasn't working directly for carmine
falcone it seems like in that moment uh
penguin is or oswald at this point i
don't know if he's called penguin yet
maybe that's just some type of
derogatory big comment penguin by the
end before he becomes penguin so just to
see pig with talking there actually was
like damn that looks so real
like dude that looks really good
but yeah but given that personal history
between them it seems like that the
start of this movie a big part of the
guilt that would weigh into bruce
wayne's motivation for what he's doing
would link heavily to carmine falcone
because part of in watching these clips
and trailers and knowing this major
ensemble of not only protagonists but
antagonists have been trying to piece
together how this could all smoothly
intersect but it seems like the jumping
off point would be with carmine which
would automatically and i feel like this
is somewhat
referenced in with the falcone family in
some way i could be wrong about this in
the comics by association thomas wayne
is like kind of protected for saving his
life oh yeah yeah it's gonna buy you a
lifetime's worth of good graces in the
mom looked it up i think i'm wrong about
that and i mean too matt reeves has been
out there talking about how he's working
on a penguin show for hbo and this being
a batman year two story and year one
having so much to do with the mob i mean
it seems like a nice transition going
from yeah obviously he has that to deal
with still with carmine but then you're
getting the rise it seems of the more
super villainous type of characters in
gotham through this movie is sort of
what i've come to imagine now and maybe
by the end penguin will arc or oswald
will arc into actually being the penguin
and getting us into a more rogues
gallery type of territory i feel like i
don't know i just get the sense that
this movie is going to start with the
mob and then slowly mount into something
crazier john turturro isn't exactly the
actor i would have picked out of a
lineup or off the top of my head but i
love just this glimpse that we're
getting of him and this like the calm
menacing energy that he's able to bring
and watching him and robert pattinson
square off because robert pattinson's
also going for a certain level of calm
menace uh
yeah i just can't wait to see what
sparks fly there like their chemistry is
so tense here but also so engrossing you
know well my favorite thing about
watching actors work together is seeing
the kind of relationships they form and
i think what's cool about the variety of
clips that we've gotten is you see
different dynamics that come into play
it's like when you see bruce with alfred
in that one clip that was released on
good morning america you see bruce is
more of this like boyish side of him
where he seems kind of like an angsty
teenager who's like getting out of my
room you know i kind of got here this is
you still have more of that sort of with
bruce wayne here where he just doesn't
want to be bruce and he's going out
there and he's got that like angsty
resistance as you know john turturro
calls it like he's as much of a recluse
as he is i like seeing that you know
when you see bruce wayne interact with
these people versus when you see these
batman clips you can see the difference
in personality like already i can tell
how people can't determine
that bruce wayne is batman because one
person behaves very different than the
other like this bruce wayne just seems
like he just doesn't want to be around
he doesn't like people he's a little bit
moody which is you know qualities of
batman but at the same time like he
doesn't seem like he's about to pick a
fight if anything here as much as he's
kind of like standing up to him and
taking some little hits at him you know
talk about the hippocratic oath being
like surprise didn't stay on the
shoreline these little jabs here or
there it still feels like john turturro
carmine falcone is maintaining the power
in this dynamic between them and that
whenever bruce sees him there is a
memory of the time he saw thomas wayne
save his life and that's my favorite
part about watching actors work together
is seeing that history and watching the
way the performances shift depending on
what the relationship is because that's
what life is you behave differently
depending on who you're around whether
that be conscious or subconscious
usually subconscious and i think that's
what robert pattinson has been really
demonstrating through all these variety
of clips like we all want to see him be
like a badass batman but it seems like
this great range of performance is
coming in when he's bruce wayne and who
he's interacting with in any particular
moment you know yeah well and the bruce
wayne moments bring a subtle element of
that detective quality to them without
it being you know like so overt you get
the sense that yeah this is like
somewhat of an uncomfortable exchange
he's playing it low-key but
also searching for the crucial pieces of
information or crucial entanglements and
things like that and it does get me
excited for the prospect that maybe this
batman movie will have the most engaged
iteration of the dark detective as well
as you know the action and all that
stuff and all the gadgetry you know and
just the general angst that comes with
the conflict between batman and his
various rogues whether they be mob or
otherwise you know ah i can't wait to
see this movie man can't wait to see it
i can't believe it's actually coming so
we're all gonna be watching
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click the notification about
leave that like button we'll catch you
guys soon
you